i thought i would do a few examples
using the angle bisector theorem so in
this first triangle right over here
we're given that this side has length
three this side has length six and this
little dotted line here this is clearly
the angle bisector because they're
telling us that this angle is congruent
to that angle right over there and then
they tell us that the length of just
this part of this side right over here
is 2 so from here to here is 2 and that
this length is x so let's figure out
what x is so the angle bisector theorem
tells us that the ratio of 3 to 2 is
going to be equal to 6 to x and we can
just solve for x so 3 to 2 is going to
be equal to 6 to x and then once again
you can you could just cross multiply or
you could multiply both sides by 2 and x
it kind of gives you the same result if
you cross multiply you get 3x 3x is
equal to 2 times 6 is 12.
x is equal to divide both sides by 3 x
is equal to 4. so in this case x is
equal to four and this is kind of
interesting because we just realized now
that this side this entire side right
over here is going to be equal to six so
even though it doesn't look that way
based on how it's drawn this is actually
an isosceles triangle it has a six and a
six and then the base right over here is
three it's kind of kind of interesting
over here we're given that this length
is five this length is seven this entire
side is ten and then we have this angle
bisector right over there and we need to
figure out just this part of the
triangle between this point this you
know if we call this point a and this
point right over here we want we need to
find the length of a b right over here
so once again angle bisector theorem the
ratio of 5 to this
let me do this in a new color the ratio
of 5 to x is going to be equal to the
ratio of 7 is going to be equal to the
ratio of 7 to
this distance right over here and what
is that distance well if the whole thing
is 10 and this is x then this distance
right over here is going to be 10 minus
x so the ratio of 5 to x is equal to 10
7 over 10
minus x and we can cross multiply 5
times 10 minus x is 50
minus 5x and then x times 7 is equal to
7x
add 5x to both sides of this equation
you get 50
is equal to 12x we can divide both sides
by 12 and we get 50
over 12 is equal to x and we can reduce
this let's see if you divide the
numerator and denominator by 2 you get
this is the same thing as 25
over 6 which is the same thing if we
want to write as a mixed number as 4
24 over 6 is 4 and then you have 1 6
left over 4 and 1 6. so this length
right over here
is going to oh sorry this length right
over here x is 4 and 1 6 and then this
length over here is going to be 10 minus
4 and 1 6. what is that 5 and 5 6.